welcome to this video yeah this video is
about round 10 game 10 of the world
championship match currently held in
sochi russia yeah we had a super dull
game nine well basically nothing was
happening and yeah I'm pretty thankful
that game ten was much better which is
probably not much of a story as you know
what can be yeah anything is more
exciting than game nine but ok you can
look forward to this game it's it's
really interesting let's see what
happened today are not playing wide and
he went with deform again so it seems
that he has made this his principal
choice for this match um the question is
um he's only got one white left out of
this game 12 hmm let's see what he's
doing there but it seems he plays deform
of the time here all right Knight f6 c4
and our cards in place okay g6 back to
the groom fault of round or Game one
carton had started with the green hurt
and it looked a little bit like one of
those yeah one-off lines just played one
time to irritate are not and after that
playing other stuff but no he's
repeating the the whole thing so the
green felt and Allen now is switching
lines in the first game he had played
this variation which is one of those
sidelines to the sideline that has
gained popularity in recent years and I
think are not in got a really decent
position probably a little bit of an
edge but this time he's playing
differently he plays Knight f3 now
Bishop g7 and queen bee three the
Russian variation as it is normally
called yeah queen bee three this is some
one of the sharpest attempts for white
and maybe also one of the most promising
and critical
um it is really not that important he
says my youtube channel is no source for
those players but I had recommended this
in my my would video series out in 2011
that's the way forward for white as a
sharp option and yeah it is really a
really popular what is why doing he's
putting pressure on d5 and black really
only can take on so far there is not
much else um move like c6 is far too
passive as why it has a very convenient
choice this is the simplest continuation
which looks like somewhat wrong Slav
exchange where the bishop especially is
misplaced on d4 blur always log against
the fortified d4 pawn after e3 yeah
black really has to take Queen takes and
now we see that we have a different kind
of Greenfeld center dnc porn i exchanged
but there is additional there additional
nights on the board and there's no
policy three so it's a little bit
different um in comparison if you
compare this with the structure with a
pawn on c3 white certainly prefers this
structure so it is really nice now with
the big center but we can put the next
move on the board Castle default but the
whole thing of course has a drawback and
this is one move two moves by the Queen
the Queen has moved two times and it is
somewhat exposed on c4 um meaning that
this is blacks main source of counter
plane that this screen is somewhat
exposed it has lost time here black is
at a crossroads he had move seven he has
a ton of moves from Bishop g4 to Bishop
e6 to c6 296 and so on the main move
nowadays is the move a six and this is
normally the the choice of the top
players intending b5 and c5 very quick
counter play I don't want to make a big
theoretical overview but this is the
main continuation cons no ever played
the move Knight to a six this is
nowadays
not that popular it is however
significant to know that this always was
the favorite line of garry kasparov swen
he was still actively playing chess he
has played this a ton of times against a
kalpa for example in World Championship
matches in awe and also an endowment
play the move Knight a6 has a very clear
plan c5 c5 is difficult to play here for
black as the queen is covering this as
well so to get in the move c5 a
certainty logical and 9 a-6 supports
this there should be two and c5 that was
the plan yeah I know white pushes d 5
i'm really without any big alternatives
and the capture here is not a good idea
it loses enormous amount of time for
example after something like bishop e6
Queen B 5 it it already starts to feel a
little bit wrong for white he has moved
the Queen far too often let's say rook
c8 and we will get this pawn back
something like this year it's really
entirely wrong for what you know um even
better by the way to flickin this and
only then give the check yeah this is a
total backwater of theory as white is
really in bad shape so you shouldn't
take on c5 I just wanted to show why the
whole thing is really clearly now the
main the main position that arises and
there's little waist deviate e6 castles
and the capture black really must play
six and capture here to open up the
ephah for counter play the big story of
this game or this line in general is
this deep own of course the deep on the
passer the middle of the board is very
typical for the gruene felt and this is
the dangerous pawn definitely and what
black needs to do here he needs to
uses active piece play to compensate for
the pawn very often black will get get
to sort of surround it and maybe a
conquer it when it is already advanced
2d six OD seven in an ideal world like
managed that and in a not so ideal word
for black at the depot on promotes and
we see that in the game it is a
dangerous it is a dangerous play here
form for both sides rook e8 was played
here's also Bishop fif as a main move
and Bishop g5 that's the first
interesting moment here Bishop g5 is not
not the main line but it has been played
in 2012 by rattles la voy a chic why is
this important yeah this is Alan's main
second nowadays so one of Arlen's help
us has played Bishop g5 only two years
ago and that is pretty much yeah a big
hint for team cards and to look at this
beforehand it was actually quite
surprising that garden still took some
time in the next couple of moves but it
is always difficult with him to to to
figure out if if he's in his preparation
or not or doing it over the board or he
actually has a preparation but he's
still thinking it's sometimes hard to
think how to him how to UM yes sort of
translate what what you see there that
the time spend and his his behavior hit
the board very hard to figure out I
actually think that quite often he is in
his prep but he's still rechecking over
the board most most things because he
yeah well it's a simple fact that he
sees more than anybody else in the world
when he when he just sitting at the
board and thinking and I think very
often he will find additional ideas or
our spots in his analysis that might
require some some rechecking yeah he
played this back to e3 this Bishop
and Bishop f5 yeah Bishop g5 and then
back to e3 looks weird but we see in the
game that there is a point to provoke h6
first yeah Bishop f5 and rook a 2d one
it is quite logical put rook here to
support the depot yeah and here in this
position in this mentioned watashi game
what does check point am i off Queen B 6
was played and somewhere in the
following moves there's probably an
improvement for why I don't want to look
at this too deeply because cars now
played a different move he played 94 and
this must have been a planned
improvement I believe we've been weird
if they didn't anticipate this position
to pop up when ya islands main second
has played it before 94 is of course a
very direct move and entirely normal for
the structure um yeah what-what are
possibilities now for white the thing is
that after night before they are
basically three moves white can take the
might this is what Anna did or you can
choose differently and a dangerous move
here would have been d6 a very direct
approach but interesting if black now
takes the pawn which is a big mistake
then Queen f4 will ultimately win this
piece it's a really a deadly deadly
situation here on the default is this
night will will get lost or some other
material black after d6 cannot take the
pawn which in itself makes it look
really dangerous yeah black however can
take here and play Queen f6 now this
leads to two very sharp plane and
difficult really difficult to to assess
the pawn sometimes even can push 37 but
yellow that's it you come to the seven
but you
going to promote yeah for example queen
bee five is an interesting continuation
here looking at the b7 porn but black
black can continue it is not a terrible
position for black can play Bishop to c4
all of the Sun to cover b7 and I think
the situation here is pretty unclear um
at least them with the normal amount of
time that that I can spend for for
looking at it I could really come up
with a conclusion if you use an engine
to check it always gives something
between equal and the slight edge for
wide but it's very difficult to really
assess this and really sort of to ya
find that the small ones the CM very
difficult position it was interesting
for wild to try but definitely part of
an ins prep am so the six wasn't wasn't
played another move by the way is not be
five which is also a fairly typical
reaction this also addresses blacks idea
with 94 I mean besides probably
sometimes to just take on c3 but one
ideas also to put the nut on d6 of
course where it would be ideally placed
to to block the deep one yeah but 95 s
mentioned it's also an option and this
is sort of anticipating 96 you can just
take it then um also interesting the
smooth night to be five it is however
not not clear what it is accomplishing
even if black plays the ultra cheeky
Bishop takes be too it's not clear that
white is actually getting somewhere
concrete or something like d6 like might
just retreat it looks totally bonkers
giving up to 28 MP issue for this city
apartment even that it's not a window
anything for wide it looks very
dangerous but it does not seem to win um
besides of course that black cannot or I
can't avoid to take on b2 which is
really looking kind of crazy and 97 for
example
an alternative yeah it's it's hard to
say those alternatives d6 on that
buffoon by 35 are definitely worth
considering however Anand took only four
and cousin recaptured with them with the
bishop let me sort of screwed up my
notes here totally Knight takes e4 and
Bishop takes my phone yeah rook checks
before is also interesting very tough
very tough to to determine the best
moves the the rook move from forces
Quincy one there's really nothing out
something like this is losing straight
away so Quincy one adhere but the Queen
placement on c1 we see one point why
Bishop g5 was inserted this Bishop g5 h6
Bishop e3 now h6 is hanging we see that
in the game as well here it is not this
relevant in this concrete line because
after night before White has yet other
things to worry about than taking age 62
hanging here but in general this is the
idea very often with this provocation of
the age six move that at some point
there might be this battery attack on
age six yeah not before a very sharp
position here that really was
interesting to look at for example a
move like Quincy five is losing right
away with rook c8 in something like that
looks really somewhat ridiculous from
White's point of view years all these
pieces in this needle clump well black
is super active and close to winning
material yeah so cannot take on c5 so
what should I play after Luke txt form
which was not played um probably d6 now
this is the most principled move pushed
the deep on
yeah I guess black just those be 6 cm
cover c5 and after a three that's the
amazing point 92 which is absolutely
necessary otherwise this whole thing is
not working for black quite quite a
funny continuation just jump in to see
to ya hear white should play Bishop d3
um yeah as you can see that this is
really a nothing at all Bishop d3 seems
to be the better move and this leads to
a very very weird position um Knight
takes III fe3 rookie 6 and Bishop takes
f5d 7 at first this looks really
ridiculous for black but it is not that
clear black can play Queen e7 and rook
t8 to block this and he has some counter
play ideas against you three um um I
don't fully trust this for black to be
ought to be perfectly honest but it's
not so clear maybe rook takes before was
playable but Carlton didn't do that he
took with the bishop it this is the more
solid choice if you want this is Bishop
recapture yeah and unplayed Quincy one
now the porn age six is really attacked
Quincy one wasn't interesting a point of
this it's wasn't the only move however
if we go back again here d6 was possible
a move that is somewhat sharper compared
to to Quincy one and I actually think
that this was maybe a chance for 400 so
not clear and Bishop c6 seems to be
there the best move other moves I think
lent black into trouble the idea of this
movies that black wants to play the
funny regrouping night too
eight and nine to d7 quite quite nice
for example something like this let's
say rook t two rooks e8 ruki one and 98
yeah note that moves like that Jim drive
you into a bad pin or b6 immediately
it's also interesting interesting is the
wrong word also good yeah an interesting
way for black to regroup if he gets gets
to d7 however still this position gives
white decent chances he has a strong
porneia and it's it's difficult to to
assess its this better or worse than the
game we can jump back in the game and as
mentioned on our plate Queen to see one
this move first attacking here yeah and
an important point now is reached if
black plays a passive move like King h7
then oops not this one and this is
really bad like King h7 white will push
the six and this this now gets
problematic the point is definitely
definitely dangerous um for example if
now Queen f6 has played in the game one
move earlier if now Queen f6 why it has
this neat little idea it's quite nice is
going to pick up this this Bishop so on
this move King age seven is too slow it
seems but council reacted just fine you
played going to f6 a counter-attack yeah
and this is very much in the spirit of
this sub variation of the goon felt
black has this active piece play with
this bishops on g74 sometimes those
night before ideas to compensate for
this dangerous pawn and very often it is
a purely tactical
feria where the the concrete lines
simply determine the outcome of the game
there's very little strategic
consideration or or long-term planning
it's just a matter of calculating is
this deep on dangerous or not yeah an
aunt now took on age six which is
basically the only continuation to to
really get to play up what what else is
there you cannot really not take so he
grabbed it Bishop age six and now
Carlton took on be too yeah it takes me
too yeah and now Alan took on be to just
basically the only move as not not
really much else takes takes yeah and
here in this position is known as 19 um
here there might be a key point of this
game I think that on move on 16 the move
d6 was was interesting at a min 15 as
well but here d 6 son is probably here
here's the position where d6 is probably
the most dangerous on it wasn't played I
don't play tonight g5 which also of
course makes perfect sense it's a good
aggressive move but as mentioned it
audit all hinges here on small technical
detail and it seems that d6 is more
dangerous we can never look d6 and now
what should like do one point is a one
idea in general is that white wants to
get in something like this attacking f7
yeah and of course simply to push the
pawn maybe get it all the way to d7 yeah
I think me move might be night before
you to try to activate the night it's
not the not the only choice something
like yeah Bishop c6 for example also
makes sense
my book activates the rook and maybe you
get in this regrouping again yeah to
block the pawn let's say Bishop c4 here
and now we are already at a very very
tactical concrete situation after be
fire for example which looks normal
white can even sacrifice yeah looks
crazy but it works and now d 7 you know
group k rook moves and the check group d
6 there are many dangerous possibilities
I mean b5 as a move that black does not
need to play I just want to show what
kind of ideas are already in the in the
mix Hanks Hanks and mmm it gets really
ugly if you get to take on g6 now there
are many additional additional tricks
like let's say like this check check and
now I can go to d6 or to a 6 a long
variation it just shows that there are
many tricky possibilities after d6 well
maybe night before is really the the
most precise but it is very difficult
even with the help of a computer you
don't get a clear conclusion if you only
let it run for like let it calculate for
four minute or two this is something
that requires much deeper analysis that
is very difficult to provide right after
the game yeah d7 for example rookie d 8
and now probably Bishop g5 not f6 check
on c4
King g7 Bishop e3 this kind of this kind
of position it's a definitely something
we're yeah we're white has pressure here
um the d7 point we'll probably get lost
with precise play for example let's say
Bishop f5 Bishop c5 and back yeah and
now like will get this but it's not so
easy and let's say Bishop d3 Bishop d7
Bishop before it's just a simple
continuation that um wait it's better to
get this inserted rook be one was my
line and then something like Bishop c8
counter-attacking Bishop before what I'm
saying is that white has the more active
pieces here bishops on C 584 um it is
not clear that it really amounts to
something very substantial at the end
but there is pressure definitely and
black has to be precise in the game
cards and also needed to be precise it's
not like it's it was totally easy but
maybe d6 is really putting black to a
somewhat sterner test then what happened
in the game this 95 move instead yeah 95
was played Bishop define that seems to
be a good defensive move centralizing
this bishop this happened or was
possible allowed because the night from
f3 was moved to g5 of course it is a
concession because black is giving up
the bishop pair and if we look at this
Bishop f3 rookie 7d 6 root g7 Bishop f4
if you look at that we definitely still
can conclude that why it seems more
comfortable if he has a good bishop pair
and also this Bishop are indecent act of
positions it's not like they're
misplaced and
the a69 is still a little bit of a mmmm
problematic piece yeah it is not really
playing or let's say it it's not really
in harmony with the rest of blacks
position so still like is forced to be
very precise i think carlton did a good
job that night too before this is
probably the best move it is an active
move and move to to put the knight on c6
and possibly allowing this double pole
on c6 it's probably something that like
it's not minding that much given the
fact that the bishop 1a3 is such a
strong piece and the double point cannot
be easily attacked here in fact a nun
played rock d 2 um it's you can argue
that I mean look to yes I just want to
show that I the point after rookie two
cards in play groupie 8 occupying the
e-file which is nice arnaud also it
could have tried a 3 intending 96 and
then work fe one this was an alternative
I mean I'm not saying that this is a
huge improvement on the game but it was
an interesting alternative that at least
keeps this control over the efr after f6
attending the right move maybe to
advance with the King on it's not clear
that this Nets so much plus black has
ideas to use this square of course with
f6 it was an interesting alternative
though rook t2 was played and now as
mentioned rookie 8 yeah look c1 and
rookie 6 this is I think very logical
the f1 rook didn't really have any other
good good spot to go to side c1 and
rookie 6 is also quite quite nice you
would like to play this yeah i mean this
is something that like definitely
welcomes but after Bishop b5
there is this return yeah all of a
sudden with a somewhat annoying pin on
the e-file it's not losing directly or
sell for black but you don't really want
to paint pin yourself so rookie six is a
good choice it prepares this movie
should be 5h form played them played by
Anand yeah this allows Bishop b5 but it
was already not easy to prevent so it's
probably right this move on at least not
not inaccurate you should be five takes
takes and now we come to the to the last
interesting position of this game um I
think definitely the worst is over for
black yeah Carlton has managed to get
rid of the bishop pair so what has
traded the dark squared bishop and was
basically forced to do the straight
after the bishop popped up on e5 so the
worst is over for black definitely but
it is not yet totally equal yeah close
but not totally anand could have tried
to continue the game um for example g3
it's not the only move but something
like that that somewhat improves the
kingside position and just continues in
a way it's not clear how black is is
equalizing there the computer is giving
be six step which is maybe not that easy
a move for a human it the computer wants
to do this this and then ultimately
maybe regroup via c6 after let's say
looks rookie a Droog c8 96-94 at the end
if everything turns out to be a
fantastic you get this in but it's not
easy to play for human and other
continuations that are a little bit more
more obvious let's say like 96 they
still offer white some some chances to
press um however I on plate surprisingly
the move Bishop takes be safe
and this is basically ending the game
because after rook takes d7 why does
obviously promoting well but after 96
black can give up his night for the pawn
and here after what you two are not
offered to draw which was accepted after
a minute think of cards it's often a
good idea when you were under pressure
before and your opponent offers you draw
it's very often in a good idea to think
for a moment and not accepted
immediately simply because it will often
happen that when you sort of have
managed to to sustain the pressure and
you're out of out of the woods in a way
very often the position is turning
completely and the opponent is just
offering a draw because he feels is
starting to stand worse and then it's a
good idea of course to to look at this
Californian maybe decline however this
position is simply totally totally equal
and cards and then accepted to draw it's
also totally fine in the method match
situation and this past porn on the C
file is sister totally no factor what
can easily always attack and stop it and
or initiate counter player on how the a
porn or somewhere else it's really and
it's really totally equal so this was an
interesting game it wasn't a really long
game with this 32 moves but it was
interesting and probably if we do look
at look bag and some key points it can
be that somewhere around here the
improvements for wild yeah might well
there might be some improvements for
what d6 here was one idea instead of
taking here d6 was interesting instead
of Quincy one and we had after Bishop
takes and doubts and Queen see one Queen
f six chicks
take stakes here the six was also
interesting those are exactly these
three spots there that could be that
they're there are the spots where white
white can improve this plane and maybe
I'll maintain some advantage even right
at the end Alan could have could have
played a little bit more decisively I
think it never was something totally
serious if you check it with an engine
it never ever shows anything more than
0.2 0.3 year it's not like there was
something totally clear but there was
pressure on cars and and with some
precision it might it could have been
could have been much much trickier I
guess so yeah what does this mean there
are only two games left and two cars and
is leading by one point he has white in
game 11 of the penultimate game and this
will be played on on Sunday there's a
rest day on Saturday on Sunday yeah
cousin with white he will try to press
but if it is just a draw I guess he does
not mind at all because if he's
confident that he can survive the last
round game with them with the draw
however we shouldn't forget that Carlton
in the last match that he won against
are not yet a very comfortable lead at
the end yet two-game lead and it was
even a three-game lead with I think game
nine when when are not over pressed or
blundered in a nice position um so we
had a really comfortable lead and he
it's just one game and he has to if it
really comes to the final game the
ultimate game I think it is something
that is not so easy for Carson I mean he
has experienced by now of course he's
not an inexperienced player of course
but compare it to announce yes
a couple of World Championship matches
under his belt and he has done things
like winning the last game yet and
against Apollo VIN 2010 for example that
was so in the last round he won the
decisive game game game 12 also at the
time so um he has managed and those kind
of those kind of things and cousins last
super high pressure situation was the
London candidates 2013 where we are lost
in the last round when he would have
qualified with the win for sure with the
draw against villa so um it is not a
clear cut thing that Carson is not
losing the last round so it is it is
still there is very suspense so I guess
cards will try with white not like
something crazy but you will try my
personal bet is that might be be a draw
because Allen might really put all this
let's say all this money on the on the
last round it's possible i don't think
that island let's say if cards in play
c4 again and will not go crazy with
black and play something totally crazy
nor will not happen so it it will be an
intense finish of this match when with
some likelihood the last round game will
have some significance i hope you
enjoyed the coverage for this game and
i'll be back on sunday with game left
thanks for watching